Guten Abend, mein Name ist Ustoole. Ich bin Arsinaf-Desire-Station. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Hafname-Geschieb beheben. Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, okay.
Ja, ist okay.
Wie heißt es Ihnen?
Ich heiße Angelika Panhorst.
Bitte Ihren Namen, Vornachnamen langsam stabieren.
Okay, Angelika schreibt sich A, N, E, L, D, K, A. Angelika.
Ja, und dann noch eine Panhorst mit A, N, N, H, U, L, S, D. Panhorst.
Fra Panhorst. Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54.
Wie bittet ihr das Akustisch?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie, Genage, Bora?
Am 28.10.1968.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 71.
Wie schwer sind Sie, Fra Panhorst?
63 Kilo.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit den letzten Tagen bei kleiner Belastung
einen Druck im Oberbau, auch einen ganz schnellen Puls.
Dann muss ich erst mal pausieren.
Ich kann mich dann nicht weiter bewegen,
treppensteigen oder so etwas.
Oder wenn ich ein leichter Puls gehe
und ich dann pausiere, wird es langsam besser.
Aber ich muss anhalten.
Okay.
Bei leichter Belastung bekommen Sie ein Druckgefühl im Oberbau.
Ja, Druckgefühl im Oberbau.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dann schlägt mein Herz auch ziemlich schnell.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Atemprobleme?
Ja, ein Stück weit kann ich dann auch nicht so gut Luft kriegen.
Das stimmt.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Also, das ist jetzt so schlimm geworden seit 3 Tagen.
Aber wenn ich so erinnern bin,
ist es seit 3 Monaten so, aber nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Dann bekomme ich schlechte Luft.
Ich habe diesen Druck im Bauch.
Ja.
Okay.
Also, wenn ich dann mich ausruhe und nichts tue,
dann habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Keine Beschwerden.
Weil ich mache sonst auch etwas Sport.
Ich jogge und ich schwimme.
Aber das mache ich letzten Tag mehr,
weil ich das schaffe.
Ich habe keine Beschwerden.
Aber das mache ich letzten Tag mehr, weil ich das schaffe.
Okay.
Haben Sie momentan irgendals Beschwerden?
Wenn ich jetzt so ruhig sitze und nicht?
Nein, okay.
Könnten Sie bitte etwas von dieser Ruckefüll berichten?
Wie ist das?
Auf einer Schmerzstikale, wobei es auch gelöscht, aber sensual.
Wenn der Schmerz dieser Druck so da ist, dann würde ich sagen 6 bis 7.
6 bis 7, okay.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Keine.
Haben Sie Hautveränderung bemerkt?
Nein, auf der Haut habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übermerksamkeit oder leiden Sie Duschwein?
Nein, alles in Ordnung.
Alles in Ordnung, okay.
Haben Sie nicht schon einmal erbrochen?
Jetzt, in den letzten Tagen?
Ja.
Nein, einmal.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Also wenn ich diese Beschwerden so habe, wenn ich mich bewege und dieser schnelle Puls so ist, dann habe ich auch manchmal etwas Schwindelgefühl, ja.
Aber jetzt zur Zeit nicht.
Okay.
Während dieser Beschwalte, fühlen Sie sich auch schwach?
Oder haben Sie nachschweiß, kältisch weiss bemerkt?
Nein, normal nicht.
Aber wenn ich diese Belastung mache und ich dann plötzlich diesen Druck kriege und diesen schnellen Puls, dann fühle ich mich schon nicht so leistungsfähig.
Da muss ich pausieren, sonst kann ich nicht weitermachen.
Okay.
Wie viel Treppe können Sie zum Beispiel auch eine Beschwerde steigen?
Zur Zeit so vielleicht zwei Stockwerke, ein bis zwei Stockwerke.
Früher war das kein Problem, aber jetzt ein bis zwei Stockwerke, da muss ich pausieren.
Okay.
Ja, Panor.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normal schlafe ich gut, ja.
Schlafen Sie mehr Kiste zum Schlafen?
Nur ein Kiste.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Sie haben keinen Duschfein, aber Verstopfung?
Haben Sie Verstopfung?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Alles in Ordnung, da bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Okay, ganz gut.
Im Besuch auf dieser Druckgefühl, im Oberbau,
rechts oder links, ist es links- oder rechts-seitig?
Der ist ziemlich in der Mitte, so unter dem Brustbein,
so in der Mitte, unter Brustbein.
Haben Sie auch enge Gefühle?
Im Bauch oder wo, meinen Sie?
Hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja, ich kann es nicht so genau beschreiben.
Es ist ein Druck und vielleicht ist es auch etwas enger Gefühle.
Ja, kann sein.
Okay, schön.
Haben Sie Konzentration Probleme?
Nein.
Das habe ich nicht.
Ganz gut, ja.
Leisen Sie eine Überschaft für die Erkrankungen?
Ja, seit meiner Jugend nehme ich ein Schilddrösen-Medikament.
Was nehmen Sie?
Unter Funktionen, das Mittel.
Das wird auch regelmäßig kontrolliert.
Einmal im Jahr gehe ich zur Kontrolle.
Okay, ich habe akustisch nicht verstanden.
Nehmen Sie Elteroxy?
Euterox.
Könnten Sie die Dosis wiederholen?
Da steht darauf 50.
Euterox 50 nehme ich morgens eine Tagelette.
Gut, okay.
Leiden Sie einen Waltheraum für die Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe noch etwas Heuschnupfen im Frühjahr.
So gegen Birkenpollen und Haselnuss.
Manchmal brauche ich dann auch, wenn es stark ist,
brauche ich einen Spray.
Aber das ist nicht oft.
Vielleicht 3-4 Mal im Frühjahr.
Nehmen Sie noch Waltheraum für die Erkrankungen?
Nein, keine Waltheraum.
Ist das Spray der Name?
Von dem Spray ist es der Name.
Ja, frage ich mich, ob Sie operiert haben.
Ich bin am Blinddam operiert worden.
Da war ich 15 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne etwas sagen.
Ich habe es in der Zeit,
um zu sagen, dass ich etwas über Ihre Lebensgewohnheit weiß.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nicht ganz gut.
Denken Sie Alkohol, gelegant nicht, oder regelmäßig?
Nein, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Ich trinke am Wochenende,
wenn wir vielleicht Gäste haben, trinke ich maximal 2 Glas Wein.
Herzklopfen?
Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden.
Okay. Haben Sie Herzklopfen? Neben dem Herzrasen?
Herzklopfen. Ja, ich habe gesagt, wenn ich mich jetzt in letzter Zeit anstrenge, dann bekomme ich diesen Druck im Bauch und bekomme auch einen schnellen Puls.
Okay.
Herzrasen oder ja, es geht sehr schnell das Herz.
Sehr schnell. Okay. Ja, ich würde gerne auch etwas über Ihre Familiengeschichte fragen.
Ja.
Ich habe eben Ihre Eltern noch, Ihre Vater.
Ja, ja, der Vater ist 81 Jahre alt, der hatte zwei Herzinfarkte und hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und die Mutter ist 80 Jahre alt und hat eine schwere Hüftatrose.
Hüftatrose.
Und wo wurde sie operiert, deswegen?
Nein, sie wollte sich nicht operieren lassen.
Er hat auch etwas, etwas Alterszucker, aber das ist wohl alles ganz gut, nicht zu schlimm.
Ganz gut, ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 56 Jahre alt, der hatte vor einem Jahr eine Operation an den Herzkranzgefäßen.
Eine Operation an den Herzkranzgefäßen.
Herr Katheter.
Okay.
Nein, keinem. Ja, Katheter auch, aber er ist dann operiert worden.
Er hat dann Bypass gekriegt.
Bypass.
Okay.
Ist momentan gesund, aber nachdem Operation hat es keinen...
Es geht ihm gut, ja.
Ich habe da noch eine Schwester, die ist 52 Jahre alt und die hat erhöhte Blutfette.
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, aber keine Kinder.
Sie haben keine Kinder.
Leben Sie nur mit Iran.
Ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich für die Panos?
Ich bin Busfahrerin.
Busfahrerin.
Ja.
Ich habe die Momentan und die Wagen dieser Beschwerden Probleme mit dem Arbeit.
Können Sie...
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Probleme, wo...
Mit der Arbeit.
Wagen aktueller Beschwerden.
Ja, also...
Momentan ab art zu sich machen, das ist momentan.
Ja, es ist letzten drei Tagen schlimmer geworden.
Und deswegen...
Ich habe gestern auch gearbeitet, das war nicht so gut.
Deswegen komme ich ja heute zu Ihnen, um mich untersuchen zu lassen, was los ist.
Sie haben gut gemacht.
Sie haben so viel gemacht, ja.
Machen Sie Sport, Regalmäßig oder gelegenen Frapanos?
Ja, das habe ich schon mal gejoggt und ich schwimme auch.
Aber das mache ich in den letzten drei Monaten, habe ich gemerkt.
Und jetzt in dem Zustand, wie ich jetzt in den letzten drei Tagen war,
kann ich nicht joggen und kann ich auch nicht schwimmen.
Das geht nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona, auch gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig eigentlich sonst zu den Untersuchungen
und im Grunde sind auch beim Berufsarzt, der hat das kontrolliert.
Das ist alles in Ordnung und Corona habe ich drei Impfungen.
Und ja.
Ganz gut, ja.
Warum sind letzten sechs Monate im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay.
Hüsten Sie Frapanos?
Hüsten Sie?
Nein, ich habe keinen Hüsten.
Ich brauche ja nicht.
Und wenn ich mal im Frühjahr Heuschnupfen habe
und etwas Reiz auf der Lunge habe und den Spreibraucher,
dann habe ich manchmal Hüsten.
Das ist früher.
Okay.
Ja.
Frapanos, möchtest du etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen Ihnen gestellt.
Möchtest du etwas hinzufügen oder etwas fragen?
Ich möchte gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Ja, Frapanos, wir haben uns eine annäherliche Gespräche geendet.
Und dass du etwas mehr sagen brauchst,
ich brauche noch ein paar Unterzüge.
Okay.
Ich werde erst körperlich unterzüge, dann ein paar Blut abnehmen.
Ich muss ihr Herz sehen.
Okay.
Aber ich vermute natürlich eine Krankheit.
Das kann ein Herzproblem sein.
Herzschwäche oder aber wie gesagt,
muss ich ein paar Unterzüge bei Ihnen düşen.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Okay.
Dann brauchen wir etwas Zeit zum Zusammenschreiben oder wollen wir gleich starten?
Nein, habe Kollegen andere Fragen.
Ich habe einige Frage.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen schon einmal im Ruhezustand erlebt?
Im Wann, im Ruhezustand?
Ja.
Nein, im Ruhezustand nicht, immer nur wenn ich mich bewege.
Wenn Sie Schmerzen bekommen,
dann ist es noch etwas derselben Seite.
Sie haben gesagt Luftnot und Herzrasen.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass der Pult sehr schnell geht.
Dann etwas Luftnot, auch ein bisschen Schwindel.
Und dieser Druck im Oberbauch,
hinter dem unteren Brustbein.
Wie lange hat eine Zochere Schmerzen an?
Wo es in den Magen geht, habe ich den Eindruck.
Wenn ich dann aufhöre, mich zu belasten,
dann braucht das 3-5 Minuten und dann ist es vorbei.
Ich habe eine Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion.
Nein.
Ich habe eine Schmuckbecher.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Nein, keine Schmuckbecher.
Ich habe eine Schmuckbecher.
Nein.
Ja, dafür beginne ich.
Gerne.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient nachhause genommen.
Ich wurde in Ihnen verursacht.
Hatten Sie dafür Zeit?
Bitte.
Okay.
Es handelt sich um Angelica Bonhurst.
Sie ist 54 Jahre alt.
1 Meter, 17kg.
Sie kann heute wegen Zeit 3 Monaten, 5 Teile handeln.
Angyna pectoris,
Suuns,
hier beschwerden,
wirden in Leicester Zeit,
Schlimma,
Bason d'Arres,
in Leicester,
Dgay Tagon,
begleitet,
begleitet sind,
zinkt diese beschwerden
Angyna pectoris
von
Palpitasus,
von Palpitasus,
Tachikardi,
Vertigo,
ja,
zinkt,
können,
ohne Pausen,
nur ein oder drei Stufen
steigen,
dann
braucht es die eine Pausen-Sumart,
Sumart,
ein oder zwei Stufen,
okay.
Sie beschrieb,
diese Druckgefühl
auf einer Schmerzskala,
ja,
bei
sechs oder sieben
von Sain,
ja,
und
sie klackt
auch über,
auch über
die Stufen
während dieser
aktuelle,
während dieser Beschwerde
ja,
dann
die Frage,
nach weiterer Beschwerde
wie
die Schwellen
beinahe,
und Haat
Veränderung, Haat-Farb-Veränderung
ja,
diese
Nectarie,
Nasia,
hier ist das Fernand,
und für
die Krankungen
ein
Hypothriose,
deswegen
die Ötrox
40 Mikrogramm
no morgens
die Rock 50 Mikrogramm, ja,
Mikrogramm, ja
und
sie leidet
auch an
Hoichnuppfung
Allergie
Nussallergie
Birkenpolin Allergie
diese
Polynose,
Polynoses
gegen Birken und Haselnuss
Polin, ja
die
sich durch
die Dispne
ösere
sie
deswegen
nimmt sie
Bay Bedarf, Salvi Tomay
Sprich, ja
ja, und sie
nimmt Bay Bedarf
oder Bay Fakultativ
Salvutamolspray
und
Seltan
ja, nicht regeln
sie
mitfümsen, apandectomiert
ja
sie ist
nicht traurig
sie trinken
auch Seltanalkol
am Wochenende
ist es gelesen
hat die Patientin
sonst Risikofaktoren?
ja
Familienanämne
ja, in der Familienanämne
findet
sich
eine
Myocardinfarkt
eine Myocardinfarkt
und
er leidet
auch an arterialen
Menschen
aus sein Bruder
ihr Bruder
ja, Bruder
hat
Weipassopie
ja
und
ihr Schwester
leidet an Hyperlipidemie
also 2 Risikofaktoren
bei Vater
und Bruder
jeweils eine KKK
Myocardinfarkt
beim Vater
und ACVB OP
beim Bruder
ja, bei Bruder
Was ist
Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
ja
meine Verdachtdiagnose
ist
eine
aber
als Differenz
die Akkorde
stabiler
und
die Arithmie
in Betracht
ja, okay
ja
ich
etwas in diesem Fall
untypisch
gut, es ist
ein
Verbrauchdruck bei körperlicher Belastung
ist ja nicht so
typisch
untypisch, aber immerhin
es wird dazu gezählt
und sie klagt
über
Tachikadie
es ist die Frage ob sie vielleicht auch
eine absolute Arithmie hat
die sie noch gar nicht bemerkt haben
ja
sie kann ja zeigen
und sie hat eine familiäre Vorbelastung
ja
durch Vater
sonst hat sie ja keine Risikofaktoren
sie raucht nicht
und sie treibt wie sie gesagt haben
auch regelmäßig
bortsonst
gut
okay, also ich finde
sie haben die Anamese
sehr systematisch
und sehr ruhig erhoben
und sie haben das nicht so
eine gute Probleme
sie manchmal zu verstehen
sie mich aber auch
der Ton ist da schwer
bei der Schilderung
vor dem Oberarzt
haben sie gleich gesagt
nicht die Patientin klagt
über Oberbauchdruck
bei Belastung
da haben sie sozusagen
schon eine gewisse Diagnose
oder Symptomatik vorweggenommen
und die Patientin stellt sich bei uns vor
mit
belastungsabhängigen
Oberbauchdruck
und leichter
Istbühne und Herzrasen
seit einigen Tagen
sodass sie jetzt
nur noch ein bis zwei Stockwerke
steigen kann
und auch keinen Spannung
leicht zu anfangen sagen sie stellt sich mit an die NAPEKTORIS vor
da würde ich erstmal
vielleicht sagen
ich habe auch Druck
und dass sie eher sagen
bei dieser Symptomatik muss man an eine
Angina Pectoris Symptomatik denken
und differenzial diagnostisch
aber sie haben die Fachbegriffe
denke ich sehr gut auch genannt
mit Tachikati
und Dispne
und Vertigo
und das fand ich alles sehr gut
haben sie gut umgesetzt
von der Patientensprache
in die
Partikel jetzt bei dem Training
dass sie das auch für die Prüfung so machen
und das denke ich haben sie sehr gut gemacht
aber wie gesagt
mit dem Ton
das war nicht immer so einfach
aber für sie ja auch
wir haben mich ja auch wahrscheinlich
verwundet
ist immer abgehackt
wann haben sie denn Prüfung
samstag
ja hoffe dass
dann die Verstimmung mit dem Ton
ist ja auch ganz klar
ja
gibt es noch
differenzial
differenzial diagnostische Überlegungen
sie haben abgefragt
mit oder das wurde ja von ihnen befracht
mit Schluckbeschwerden
mit Reffluxbeschwerden
das wurde ja alles verneint
also es
spricht glaube ich eher
weniger für eine
für eine Magen
Ursache dieser Beschwere
hat keine gastronomistischen
Probleme
ja
ja also insofern ist es auch wichtig
denke ich eher
auch ans Herz zu denken
natürlich
differenzial diagnostisch auch andere
Organsysteme mit
mitbetracht zu ziehen
aber so ist glaube ich die Symptomatik relativ typisch
belastungsabhängige
die Beschwerden
die nach Pause
sich wieder bessern
aber dann schnell wieder auftreten
wenn sie sich belastet
ja
ja gut
ich denke mir sie werden die Prüfung
am samstag gut schaffen
und wünsche ihnen dafür alles Gute
viel Erfolg für die Prüfung
wir
können in den
nächsten 14
Tage
weil ich nicht weiß wo wir hinreisen
können wir in den nächsten 2 Wochen
leider nicht trainieren
aber dann wieder
ist das schlimm
frage an den Moderator
ich verstehe nicht
nächste Woche
nein
die nächsten 2 Wochen
können wir nicht
können wir uns nicht verabreden
also
erst wieder in 3 Wochen
ja ok
ich kann
es
geht leider nicht die andern
ich kann
diese Annemnesgespräche anfangen
sagen
etwas sagen
zum Beispiel
Frau Panhorst
hat sich bei uns
wegen der Monaten
bestehender progredienter
sie
erwidert
die饅ti
und
die
etwas kurze Satze sprechen. Ich bin ein Freund von kurzen Sätzen. Weil kurze Sätze sind nicht so
gefährlich. Wenn Sie einen langen Satz machen, kann es passieren, dass die Konstruktion zu
schwierig wird, zu kompliziert. Deswegen lieber kurze Sätze, bin ich ein Sympathisant von.
Kurze Sätze, ich etwas besser. Man macht nicht so viele Fehler.
Ja, ich denke es wäre besser, ob er Bauchschmerzen,
Anzosen, ob er Bauchschmerzen, der Epigastrialschmerzen.
Ja, man kann vielleicht sagen, Frau Panthost ist eine 54-jährige Patientin, die sich wegen
belastungsabhängiger epigastrischer Druckschmerzen oder Druck im Oberbauch,
im Epigastrium, bei uns vorgestellt hat. Punkt. Nicht länger den Satz, lieber dann einen neuen Satz machen.
Ich glaube, es ist für die Prüfung besser.
Ja, und die Verneuseien der Patienten folgen die Begleissymptome bei Schmerzen aufgefallen.
Bis zu den Ärzten.
Aber mit Schmerzen bei Begleissymptomen.
Wichtig ist, dass die Grundrichtung ist, bei belastungsabhängiger Schmerz oder Druckschmerzen,
und der bei Ruhe oder bei Pausieren, assistiert dieser Schmerz.
Also hört euch, stopp der ja.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Diese Patientin, die Begleissymptome, gibt aber,
wir können welchen, welchen, zum Beispiel im Krankenhaus, im Notfall,
eine Bundesgeschefung führen oder einen Kursepause machen.
Aber die Patientin hat ja gesagt, auf Befragen, dass diese Beschwerden so ähnlich schon seit circa 3 Monaten bestehen,
aber nicht so stark. Sie hat das gemerkt beim Joggen, beim Schwimmen,
dass sie vielleicht nicht mehr so leistungsfähig ist oder nicht mehr so gut joggen kann.
Und das hat sie bemerkt und dann ist das mal ein Prozess.
Es ist nicht so ganz abrupt.
Und deswegen, manche Patienten sind da sehr sensibel und spüren das,
aber manche wollen es ja auch nicht wahrhaben, sie verdrängen es.
Das ist das Problem.
Gut, dann würde ich jetzt sagen,
drei Wochen halb, gut mir leid, dass die Tonverbindung nicht so gut war.
Vielleicht liegt es hier an dem Gewitter, was jetzt bald kommt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich wünsche Ihnen eine gute Prüfung und dass wir uns dann in drei Wochen wiedersehen.